26 republican governors now want action
and they are now demanding president
biden meet with them within the next two
weeks yeah they have a deadline on this
they've written a letter all together
and you see at the end of the letter
they've all signed it as chief
executives of our states we request a
meeting with you at the white house to
bring an end to the national security
crisis created by eight months of
unenforced borders
it's about a page and a half
three of those governors are in focus
now
doug ducey of arizona asa hutchinson of
arkansas and brian kemp of georgia
gentlemen great to have you on the
program first of all
uh governor ducey i want to start with
the letter
and really get a drill down on what
you're hoping to accomplish because we
in the press can't even get the the
president to take our questions
well it's time for the biden
administration to act border security
has been seen as something that the
southern states have to deal with on the
border the reason that you have governor
hutchinson and governor kemp here from
arkansas and georgia is because
something that's become national
security because we don't know who's
coming over the border has become public
safety the drugs and crime that we're
seeing rising in our states and flooding
over the border is infecting our schools
and neighborhoods more than half the
nation's governors all republican have
demanded a meeting with president biden
we know how to fix this situation it's a
federal issue we want to work with them
but the time for action is right now
well look the federal government is not
responding to requests for help and and
all of it uh governor kemp and you know
at one point you would think that the
white house would get back with a plan
they did send fema several months ago
and now they've asked for more troops
but we have i mean for some troops we
have a situation that's more urgent than
a plan on a wall
well harris we have over 200 georgia
national guard troops down there now
they have been for a long time and i
visit them back at the end of the trump
administration and what's happening now
and what's happened uh just several
months ago in mcallen texas drastically
different because the policies have
changed the messing messaging has
changed from the biden administration
and they need to act i mean we're glad
to send more troops but the question to
me as i heard the the tape earlier about
the apprehensions what about the people
that aren't being apprehended how many
people are coming across undetected it's
the governors are going to have to deal
with those individuals yeah we you know
we struggle to get exact numbers in real
time and they will release a number at
the end of each month but it helps to
know in real time we know it's about 3
000 people every day now that are trying
to get into this country
the president put the vice president in
charge of this though i want to get to
that and then governor hutchinson i'll
come right to you vice president kamala
harris finally speaking out now on the
border crisis but only to condemn border
patrol agents on the front lines who
were accused of mistreating haitian
migrants in del rio let's watch
what i saw depicted about
those individuals on horseback
treating human beings the way they were
is horrible
and i fully support what is happening
right now which is a thorough
investigation human being should never
be treated that way
and i'm deeply troubled about it
i'm curious to know how much digging in
on all the facts she's done because
maybe they could tell us exactly what
she thinks is going on but the
democratic congressman from texas henry
cuellar took a different stance on
things he defended those border patrol
officials watch
if there was a problem it should be
investigated and i think that's it but
we cannot paint
the border patrol with the same type of
paintbrush uh look you know they what
are they supposed to do just stand there
and let everybody come in uh you know
they're supposed to be enforcing the the
law
governor hutchinson this has been going
on for eight months and the one incident
that this vice president leans in on is
something that as you heard a democrat
says simply needs to be investigated
it's not the whole kit and caboodle of
what's going on on the border
well the border patrol is what is
standing in supporting our national
security we need to support our border
patrol they're doing
an amazing job with difficult challenges
as the congressman said if there's any
issue it can be reviewed but by and
large they have a very very difficult
job let me uh emphasize a couple points
uh first of all
this all started as governor ducey said
because there's a change of policy in
the bible administration secondly the
wrong signal was sent
to our
counterparts across the globe that we
have an open border and this is the
result of it that is a border in chaos
the only way you can
reverse that and i think the bite
administration sees the need to do it is
that you've got to change policy but
even more significantly you've got to
put federal resources there that sends
the signal that we're serious about
protecting the border these are not
complicated steps these need to be done
the fact that 26 governors have signed
that letter is a strong signal that
this is amiss and that's really
adversely impacting all of our states
you know i want to talk now about the
implications of you having to knock on
the door of the white house for lack of
a better term when you write a letter
like the one that you've written
and um
governor kemp that that has to be an
outlier in how normal business is done i
mean
i i have to think that there's some
level of frustration that it's come to
this normally you'd just be able to pick
up the phone wouldn't you i mean you're
a chief executive all of you of your
states reaching out to our nation's
chief executive i would imagine he'd
want to take a call
governor campbell i think the front yeah
the frustrating thing for me harris is
you know when you're in the executive
branch your your constituents and the
citizens of your state and your country
want to take action when there's a you
know a crisis and unfortunately the vice
president in this task force
i haven't seen anything from them about
any policy positions or changing
anything from the disaster that we're
seeing right now in this current
situation in del rio
this is one of the examples this has
been going on as you've mentioned for
months and months
we're willing to help you know i know
i'm willing the georgia national guard
to send more people but they got to ask
for that so it's not just we're
demanding something we want to be part
of the solution as well but like
governor hutchinson said this is a
federal issue the federal government is
supposed to protect our borders
we're glad to help but i've been on
tours with the texas state troopers on
the river down there because they're
having to go patrol the border because
the federal government will not that's
outrageous to me and the states are
going to deal with gang members human
trafficking fentanyl and other things
that are flooding across it's already
cancelled
yeah it's already happening which is why
you guys have have banded together um i
i don't know if we've got the video from
over the weekend but they had to take
patrol cars law enforcement and border
patrol to stop the people flowing into
the country they had to build a
barricade
of vehicles to keep the human beings
from crossing into the country they all
have to be processed and now we learn
governor ducey and and you're the border
state in all of this
we know from governors kemp and
hutchinson that this is going to fan out
in ways of drug cartels and sex
trafficking and those horrible
situations the immediacy is
what about those families living along
the border what's happening to them
governor ducey what's happening to their
lives
these ranchers are under assault their
way of life has dramatically changed and
this white house doesn't listen to
governors it doesn't value governors it
doesn't talk to the governors it looks
at us as lower middle managers in their
federal corporation where is kamala
harris she hasn't come to arizona
secretary mayorkas is non-responsive and
joe biden is trying to change the news
by doing vaccine mandates we are asking
for help
from the federal government we will
partner with them we've deployed our
national guard other governors have sent
law enforcement to places like arizona
and texas and we're grateful but we need
the full faith and force of the federal
government and we should be supporting
the border patrol they're down there
they're they're for with this
administration's giving them 19th
century technology when we know that
walls work we know that drones work we
know that surveillance works and then
there should be a clear message that the
border is not open joe biden and kamala
harris both raised their hand in the
first debate and said they would offer
free health care to people that
illegally cross the border they need to
correct their messaging right away well
can we get them vaccinated if we're
going to let them fan out all across the
country i mean we're in the middle of a
pandemic does the white house care or
not and any governor can take that we'll
just ride your mic and make sure we
follow you
well that's the other part of this we
talked about the the national security
crisis we talked about the public safety
crisis you can see the humanitarian
crisis when you look at del rio that
should be
labeled bidenville until they clean this
up and then there's the public health
crisis that we're experiencing we're all
battling we're
promoting and advocating vaccines trying
to keep our citizens safe and the
administration seems to forget about
that as people come over the border
illegally they should be returning them
to their country they should be
enforcing title 42 they should be
finishing the wall and they should be
sending a clear message that the border
is not open
well thank you for giving our viewers on
the faulkner focus an idea of exactly
what you're going to say to the
president should you sit down just real
quickly anybody heard from the president
since you sent your letter yes or no
no
nothing
we'll stay honest we have it yet
governors thank you very much for your
time today chief executives in your
state one of 23 of 26 that are demanding
a meeting with the president of the
united states appreciate your time
thank you wow did you hear him
they're calling it bidenville now down
at the border